two of the biggest films of 2016 Captain
America Civil War and Batman vs Superman
dawn of Justice had nearly the same plot
this isn't the first time Hollywood made
two movies with the same story at the
same time how does this happen and which
of the movies did fans like more let's
find out
dawn of Justice versus civil war even
though Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice and Captain America Civil War
may have come out at nearly the same
time large chunks of each were based on
comic books published 20 years apart
DC's The Dark Knight Returns came out in
1986 and Marvel Civil War came out in
2006 dawn of Justice got the jump by
arriving in theaters first but when it
comes to battles between superhero films
about battles between superheroes
Captain America Civil War is the clear
winner not only did it easily blow past
Batman vs Superman box office take in a
matter of days it also has a 90% fresh
rating on Rotten Tomatoes compared to
just 27% for Batman vs Superman pow the
equalizer vs. John wick the equalizer
and John wick arrived in theaters less
than a month apart in the fall of 2014
and they shared a couple specific major
plot points both have a lead character
who is a retired hitman dealing with the
death of a beloved wife and both come
out of retirement for personal reasons
to exact revenge on the Russian mob what
kind of monsters kill a guy's dog the
similarities didn't seem to affect the
performance of either movie both were
box-office hits and paved the way for
sequels I'm taking on back Olympus has
fallen versus White House down back in
2013 it was no secret that both Sony and
millenium films were making movies about
terrorists attacking the White House the
competing projects publicly raced each
other to see which could land the bigger
stars and get released first agent
gerard butler and president aaron
eckhart hit theaters first with Olympus
has fallen with agent channing tatum and
president Jamie Foxx following just a
couple months later in White House down
how can you not having that with the
rocket while trying to talk both films
were moderate successes at the box
office but neither could it big though
Olympus has fallen got a poorly reviewed
sequel in 2016 London has fallen
turns out fictional politics just can't
match the entertainment factor of the
real thing no strings attached versus
friends-with-benefits paramount and
Screen Gems had a bit of a pickle on
their hands in 2011 not only were they
both making movies about couples who
start off casual only to fall in love
but both films have the same name
friends with benefits
paramount eventually blinked changing
the name of their movie to no strings
attached
it barely mattered both Friends of
benefits and no strings attached were
huge hits at the box office apparently
it was an idea whose time had come twice
Megamind versus Despicable Me it's easy
to see the similarities between 2010
Despicable Me and Megamind
they're both animated features about
supervillains who aren't really bad guys
at all which they prove after stopping
an actual villain from conquering
everything and the critics took notice
hammering mega mine for being too
similar to Despicable Me which had
opened earlier in the year but the main
difference that turned Despicable Me
into a worldwide phenomenon wasn't
timing it was those loveable minions it
just goes to show that the old Hollywood
adage is still true never mess with a
talking Twinkie skyline versus battle
Los Angeles these two films about aliens
attacking LA were just a little too
similar for battle los angeles producer
sony pictures they threatened to sue
skyline directors colin and greg strauss
because the company they use for skyline
special-effects had also been hired by
sony to do special effects for battle
los angeles sony alleged that the
Strasse brothers had stolen the idea
from them or at least some of the
special effects but eventually decided
not to bother suing they probably
figured los angeles couldn't survive
another battle so soon the prestige vs
The Illusionist
it's one thing when Hollywood coughs up
two films about general concepts like
alien invasions it's another when two
films come out at the same time about a
highly specific topic like the world of
stage magicians in the late 19th century
somehow though that's exactly what
happened in 2006 with the prestige and
the illusionist what happened
was the greatest magic trick I've ever
seen both featured stellar casts and
both did well at the box office but it
was the prestige that earned the
prestige pulling two Oscar nominations
out of attack compared to just one The
Illusionist Deep Impact vs. Armageddon
finally there's deep impact and
Armageddon fueled by fears at the end of
the millennium would also bring about
the end of the world audiences in 1998
were primed for films about giant
asteroids crashing into Earth and both
films became box-office smashes rejoice
and what we have been we given
our planet most people probably don't
even remember deep impact though while
Armageddon has entered legend as one of
the cheesiest blockbusters of all times
hard to believe but deep impact just
wasn't quite dumb enough
of course that stupid Aerosmith song
playing on endless repeat on the radio
since 1998 probably helped ensure that
we'd never ever forget Armageddon for as
long as we lived
I don't
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which movies you
think won the battle